single women own
2.64 million more homes than single men
in the U.S let me finish this article so
let me say that one more time
single woman on
2.64 million
more homes
than single men in the U.S okay on an
average woman earns around 83 cents for
every dollar they earn okay compared to
a man in the U.S single woman on a total
of 10.76 million homes whereas single
men own 8.12 million there's a
difference of 2.6 for it and the Gap is
growing and 48 out of 50 states single
women were found to own more homes the
two exceptions were North and South
Dakota
which only three people lived there and
then Louisiana Alabama and South
Carolina had the greatest share of
single women homeowners Louisiana
Alabama and South Carolina on average
across the three states single women
owned 15 percent of all owner occupied
houses
where a single men owned 11 percent
although men earn more than women on
average that is not always true for
younger generation according to new Pew
research
uh Center younger women
women younger than 30
earn more than men and cities including
New York DC and LA
let me read that last sentence to you
again according to peer research center
women younger than 30 earn more than men
in New York Washington DC and LA
what do you think about this these stats
so the first stats like surprised me a
little bit but then I kind of clicked
for me where um remember the video we
did on a single moms versus dads that
had kids yeah so the far majority go
with the mom right and at that point who
needs a house if you have kids to
provide for versus no kids so if you
kind of correlate or if you add the
single mothers with kids that are taking
care of them into custody versus a
single dad that's taking care of it in
custody then the crossover there I can
see how those numbers make sense but
then but then okay so if your argument's
gonna be divorced I just pulled up the
top states 10th states with the highest
rates of divorces New Mexico is number
one West Virginia so what if you never
got married
kids out of wedlock or kids you never
get married where a couple splits up but
they've never had a legal marriage then
you're not divorced you're just we're
just parting ways uh so his house goes
to her no he he never had a house she
has need for a house yes because she has
the kids yeah but she's taking care of a
kid and and uh I'm not saying yes then
probably he's less money to be able to
buy a house but you'd also need a house
in that situation more so than I
understand you need a house there's a
difference between needing a house and
affording a house absolutely affording
yes
but who's like again that was where I
was looking at it but the more
interesting thing is what about the pay
inequality what about that whole
argument yeah I mean in three major
cities this is new uh under 30 women are
being paid more
that's that's sexist is that also can
you pull up that article by the way just
zoom in a little bit is that maybe
because uh women under 30 more of them
are going to school and getting a higher
education and especially if you're in
one of those three states they're very
for equality in terms of pay and equal
opportunity then you have younger people
who are higher educated by the way I
want to continue to read this article
I'm actually curious right now okay so
we talk about North Dakota and South
Dakota okay great in Florida Maryland
and Delaware the difference in home
ownership between single men and women
was the greatest across the three single
women on average owned around 4.5
percent more homes than men we're
talking Florida Maryland and Delaware
there is no correlation between those
three states it's interesting women are
paid less than men on average and earn
83.1 percent of what men earn according
to U.S Department of Labor the figure
compares the median wage of all
full-time male and female workers in a
country using data from 2020 and as the
most comprehensive analysis of the
gender wage Gap to date according to the
data from National Association of
realtors in 2020 to 19 percent of buyers
for single women whereas just nine
percent were single men in 2015 single
women made up 16 percent of the buyers
were single men made only nine percent
and the gap between Sigma that is very
weird to look at this so
um I think if you if you think about who
prepares more for a rainy day that
mindset I I'm gonna give that Victory to
women yeah who thinks more long term by
saying let me at least buy a house and
you know make some kind of an investment
this is a
and if they're single pet and they're
dating then they're not paying for
drinks popcorn at the movies they're not
paying for dinners of course they got
money to buy out house they're not out
spent you know I mean because those
girls it's they're single it's not that
they're not dating you feel me Rob
robbers Rob's in love yeah you're
married
that's nuts this is a everybody here
spooked a little bit
is that for sure yeah are you still
spooked Roger or is this making you
think a little bit I'm I'm not making a
lot of sense out of it me too because
I'm trying to figure out why why those
three specific cities is very
interesting Florida Delaware America
well but also New York L.A L.A
Washington DC
the government's the biggest employer
right that makes sense yeah but I can't
figure out why the other two but by the
way this is a uh this is a story to okay
men typically purchase homes that were
249 000 last year compared to women who
purchased homes that were 20 or 30
that's not a big difference yeah it's
not even 10 it's five percent difference
in our sacrifices women are generally
more uh more likely to make included
cutting out non-essential spending
taking second jobs it's kind of like
what you're talking about canceling
vacation plans yeah okay there you go
very interesting article I'd love to see
more stats and data uh on uh on this
here I'm canceling my date this weekend
Pat you guys she's paying for it um
she's paying for it I'm looking at the
houses you're a homeowner I don't have a
house yeah I live in an apartment yeah
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign